[Music]
so title the talk is fixing big data
engineering with sequel the parentheses
around the big is actually because what
is big data what is in big data and also
data engineering best practices
principles can be applied and should be
applied no matter how big your data is
so sort of without being too grandiose
you know universal truths and all that
sort of thing also you'll note that
there's quite a few names at the bottom
of this presentation is just talking and
myself here today however a lot of what
we're gonna be talking about was
information that we incrementally
discovered along the way and tons and
tons of people have contributed to this
both EDT oh these people are all leads
in the data reliability engineering team
at crece oh but also outside at
conferences like this so so quickly
about us so we work at the data
reliability team in créteil Crito for
those who don't know is a pretty big
tech company we have about two billion
well 2.5 or something billion dollars in
revenue annually and the scale of things
that we do is pretty big half a billion
or half a trillion records ingested
every day 28 petabytes of data processed
you know hundreds of thousands of cores
etc etc we just were talking to one of
the leads on the protobuf project at
Google and we told him about our scale
he said well you guys might be the
biggest company outside of Google using
protobuf so or the biggest law the the
heaviest users of protobuf outside of
google so he's actually happy about that
so anyway also a major difference
between us and the rest of the world is
we're bare metal we grew up that way
we have latency constraints for
displaying ads so back in the olden days
the cloud wouldn't give any guarantees
about latency and so that was that was
critical and then we just sort of
learned how to how to do that so what
are we gonna talk about so first I'm
going to define a few
a few things so we can all sort of work
with the shared understanding now you
can disagree with my definitions that's
fine but for the purposes of my talk
they're important then we're gonna talk
about imperative data pipelines so sort
of the old way of doing things and then
we'll talk about a declarative world and
then talk a little bit about how this
works at could you so first of all what
is data engineering
well it's fuzzy I had a different set of
slides on this for a different talk
where I I sort of made fun of all the
definitions that are running around on
Google but I've sort of tried to
consolidate consolidate it down to two
things
and that's basically either building the
pipelines or building the systems this
is actually important because the same
people don't like to do the same two
things actually it's it's I always
thought that building pipelines was your
gateway drug to want you become a
systems engineer but as it turns out we
actually have a quite a few people a
creature who don't care about building
systems or tools they actually just like
building those pipelines and so this
distinction I think is important the
other thing that I that I'd like to add
to this definition is why we do this and
we do these things to either
I think extract information out of the
system so observe what happened and I
would consider that classic bi and we
also nowadays do do this to inject
intelligence into the system and that
would be AI now of course we can do
machine learning stuff and statistics
and whatnot and bi but I would say that
the the act of injecting intelligence
back into the system feeding that back
in through sort of a feedback loop to
your online transactional systems is the
AI slash deep learning you know fancy
stuff I think most people consider this
hard there's conferences about it
and so I think if it's not hard for you
I think it's complicated for everybody
okay big data so again what is big data
right okay the three V's right so of
velocity variety volume I think other
companies have extended the number of
V's I have no idea in any case it's it's
you know basically you're dealing with
problems that need to be distributed
because your data set is so big that's
that's how I sort of classify it and
some
times will add advanced transformations
into that so the deep learning stuff but
not always right a lot of times we're
just doing old-school stuff in a new
environment now why do we have big data
well I think I don't know Sergey Brin
who said our algorithms aren't better
than yours we just have more data so
that I think that just set us all off to
the races right the more data points we
have the more intelligence we can we can
get or get out of get out from the
system or put back in and of course we
all know this is hard and complicated
okay so what's the date of data
processing pipeline well it's a series
of operations on data with a specific
order of operations right so the
previous talks talked about DAGs and
whatnot so obviously there's a dag
involved sometimes we can paralyze some
of the operations we can paralyze some
of the nodes in the dag we can paralyze
portions of the dag but fundamentally
we're reading a bunch of data we're
doing some transformations and we're
writing a bunch of data out and I'd like
to say that this is also considered hard
and complicated and it's even harder and
more complicated in a big data setting
okay
so TL DR we could have skipped all that
we're just doing UTL I think you know
there's a lot of people who don't like
that qualification or classification of
what we do
but I think it's useful first of all it
grounds us so we stopped thinking that
we're really fancy people all we're
doing is you know plugging a and B into
a system to produce C or a B prime or
whatever and then we can compose all
this stuff together and make really big
ETL systems okay so we have some
definitions handled and so let's talk
about what imperative pipelines are so
avert your eyes those who don't like
pearl I thought this was a it was fun to
write some pearl it's been a while so
anyway so I wrote this little script it
works it's correct this is a single
threaded way to imperative lis transform
some input data right so basically what
are we doing I'm detailed on the entire
script but basically are taking some CSV
data and doing some aggregations on it
to get the distinct number of clickers
so this is apparently clickstream data
and the number of clicks grouped by our
okay so here's an imperative data
workflow that some people who are old
enough in this room might recognize this
sort of operation we're gonna SCP some
data in from our our hosts it's gzip so
we're gonna gzip GZ cat it pipe that
into our little processing script and
then we're gonna probably pipe that into
some script that's going to load that
into a database and it creates this
little dag here okay so why is that
imperative well because we're telling it
specifically what to do right and how to
do it so a quick analysis so first of
all it's actually has a quite a lot of
nice properties right it's pretty easy
to understand the test like anybody can
understand that system it's actually
fairly efficient that ran on my old
MacBook Pro at the speed of about
250,000 records per second so I mean you
know that's fine it's modular right we
can reuse those bits and pieces for
different for different purposes it's
also very unix ii write unix was built
around this sort of thing unix is has
worked for a long time and so if you're
a UNIX person that also kind of feels
good it makes you it's like comfort food
for the UNIX soul and but on the other
hand it's totally fragile right there's
some like very very fragile parsing code
in there we could quickly overrun memory
with the way we're doing the
aggregations you know so it's quite
fragile
err reporting you know there's none
you've got standard out standard error
if you know anything's gonna go out
that's useful so yeah so that's not
great it's also only easy to modify if
you wrote it and that's not just a joke
on Perl any of these scripts you can get
that way right and it's not gonna scale
beyond a single machine unless you
really really really try very very hard
right distributing those algorithms it
can be tough right that's why MapReduce
exists and all that good stuff so those
are problems so basically the
distributed problem is the one we're
going to talk about because that's
principally why we're here right we're
all passed single machine scale and
when there's more than one machine in a
system all this stuff breaks and so now
we need to write complex distributed
programs and the semantics of those
things are actually difficult to master
so you know it's all very hard costly
and it becomes difficult to modify so
declarative data processing so we're
gonna use sequel here in our examples
we'll talk a little bit more about some
other paradigms as well but principally
we're gonna use sequel as the device so
here's that same transformation with a
nice little sequel query it's pretty
trivial to read I'm on detailed for you
what do we get when we go to declarative
data transformation paradigm well first
of all we get a better distinction
between the Declaration of what we want
to do and the runtime so now we can
compile we can optimize we can do all
kinds of fancy stuff we can ensure
semantics around how the joins are done
what can be parallelized what can't be
all this stuff comes the system gives
you all these sorts of guarantees and
you as the person who just needs to
transform some data you don't have to
think about any of that so that
increases everybody's productivity and
also expands the population of people
who can do stuff right so it's not just
the one expert in the back room who can
who can write that Perl code or whatever
you know pick your scripting language of
choice and also the compilation phase
especially with a relational algebra
like with sequel you can start doing
things like reordering things
eliminating steps can you know really
tackle an optimization problem so a
sidebar so we're going to talk about SQL
here principally but I did want to
address declarative data transformation
in other languages so functional
programming allows us to do lazy
evaluation of declarative programs as
well and frameworks like spark scalding
and shio they allow you to do that right
the operations like flat map map all the
monadic stuff allows you to do very
similar things however this only
describes the pure transformations and
the operators that you you have access
to in those
in those paradigms and so you can see
here that with this this is just a cut
and pasted cut cut and pasted code from
spark example page and you know famous
word count and what we can see is that
this code is nice it's very easy to read
very understandable but it's actually
fragile so first of all we have
hard-coded sources and sinks for our
data so you know that's built into the
program that's not so great we'd rather
inject that into the program you'll note
that we're also talking about how like
we're saving it out as a text file maybe
we don't want to save in a text file
maybe want to save it in parque you know
that sort of thing and then also this
works by lambdas and in particular
closures and so those closures can
encapsulate nasty things that we can't
serialize over the pipeline to you know
distribute the program they can also do
nav nasty side effects that inject
non-deterministic operations and so your
pipeline becomes fragile non replayable
etc etc also you see that the parsing
logic is built into this we're doing a
line dot split function on the we're
doing split function on the line and so
that means that we're binding the actual
job logic with the way we deserialize
the data from disk which isn't very
satisfactory either because like we all
said maybe the days are gonna get big
and they were going to change it to
parquet or whatever protobuf whatever
you want to do and when we do that now
we have to go modify all this code and
all these jobs so that's that's
unpleasant as well from a maintenance
perspective okay so so FB is great we do
lots of functional programming creature
we have lots of scalding and spark and
also the stuff in production but these
are some of the limitations of that so
scheduling it so let's switch so that's
so ok assuming you're all still with me
and you all agree with all my conceits
and all this other stuff we've all
agreed that declarative data
transformation was great and ideally
sequels is you know is is the right is
the right way to express them so that's
cool
but now we have to actually schedule
them and scheduling them is different
than running them once right when we run
them once we parameterize them ourselves
we check the inputs and outputs and we
say oh that's good I like it but now we
need to automate that and so
we have there's frameworks out there so
if a chi airflows talked about this
morning we have one we call cuddle same
basic thing it's written in Scala
but it's effectively the same thing and
actually I'd argue that what's going on
there is actually imperative
I mean it's lazily it's it's lazy
declarative and also other stuff but it
is actually you're specifically telling
the scheduler in which way in what order
and whether those things can be
paralyzed the different job units so
that's actually dangerous because the
job is the one that actually needs to
know what the data is what the
parameters are and in many times you're
actually expressing those things inside
the jobs from inside the job itself and
so this is this is duplicated to inject
this kind of dependency declaration as
the data chorale speaker said before the
sequel statements can tell you exactly
what they depend on there's from there's
joint there's you know all the
dependencies are actually directly in
the in the query so this is actually
dangerous and this is real-world
declarative dag code this is in
production at Crete co this is using our
scheduler cuddle this is scalding this
is orchestrating scalding code and I
would argue that that's incomprehensible
I don't know I don't know what that's
doing right and I challenge anybody to
tell me if that's correct right it's
impossible to determine there's there's
offsets that are being managed because
log a depends on three hours of log B
you know so sliding window stuff and is
that are the actual job units themselves
deterministic you don't know because you
don't know the joint matching you know
you have no idea here is this replayable
or not you can't really the scheduler
can't know you can only hope that those
job units have been coded in a way that
it's replayable so this is really
unsatisfactory and it's actually unsafe
it's but it's creature code so it's good
but anyway and we wrote it that's our
scheduler so so okay so let's switch to
declarative scheduling and so sequel
exposes basically everything we need so
first of all we have our data set
dependencies so you can see that we're
binding
Raw clicks in the default schema and we
need a day and hour and we're going to
parameterize the the job by that with
those question marks we can also see
that we have a candidate partitioning
key in the day our concatenation and we
also have an output schema that we can
use we can recycle for later potential
children of this data set so it's
actually really nice right the job
itself you write the job and you can
actually know what you should do with it
to schedule it well almost
so the query by itself actually doesn't
tell you about the domain of that
partition key so here this is time so
everybody can say oh I know what time is
right but actually you're not always
going to just be dealing with time
partitions so for example crece o has
multiple data centers and we do
incremental processing based on the data
center the data comes in from just as a
way to optimize and batch and so we need
to know that as part of the scheduling
semantics so here I've taken days and
pets right so we need to know this
domain of pets
it's an enumeration and we need to we
need to the scheduler needs to know
about it because it needs to have a
target right so here we're missing cat
for Tuesday and so the scheduler is like
oh my god there's a missing cat and we
need to go deal with that on the other
hand today's Thursday and we have like a
24 hour SLA or whatever so we're fine
over here at the tail end we know that
ferret will be computed it still has
time to be computed before we're going
to consider it a missed scheduling and
of course it's Thursday and so we can't
possibly compute Thursday yet because we
don't we haven't completed Thursday so
ok so how are we going to do this well
we're gonna actually extend sequel a
tiny bit so here we can see that we're
explicitly stating that for each T in
the time series hourly we're going to
create partition of T casted as a date
time so this actually makes the domain
of the partition entirely explicit so I
talked I spoke about custom enumeration
so we can actually do that as well so we
can have two variables and so you could
actually sort of look at this as a for
comprehension as well for the functional
people out there but we're also explicit
in now the seria another series which is
an ad hoc series which are our host
platforms so these are groupings of data
centers Asia EU and US and so now we're
gonna partition by both of those and the
scheduler can now knows exactly what the
target is right the the scheduler can go
back and build this it can build this
table once it has that there's also
sometimes things change right especially
when we're talking about enumerations
right so sometimes so for a period of
time we dabbled with going into China so
that was great it didn't work out but
for about a year we had a data center in
China and so that was an additional
platform and it's really important to
have these semantics in your in your
scheduler because if you just stick with
the larger set China so you include
China well your scheduler is going to
consistently report there's a bunch of
errors because China's not there right
if you get rid of China but you still
have China data sitting out there when
you do replay it you're going to forget
about that so this versioning is
actually pretty important and we're able
to encapsulate that with this sort of
extension tense QL so okay so that's
great so we've solved the problem Yahoo
you know it's all go drink beers tonight
but we do have some trade-offs so
generally speaking the higher level the
abstraction the more constrained we are
and what we can do that's obviously a
good thing and a bad thing on the good
side of things this means things can be
better understood safer that sort of
thing
but then we can't always express exactly
what we wanna do it can also lead to
harder testing because you're probably
at a very very very very high
abstraction level so you're probably
depending on quite a lot of things and
if some of those things if the
abstraction is not very good
MapReduce and you know things start
breaking underneath the hood it becomes
difficult to trace that in debug it
and not all declarative languages sequel
lend themselves to co-chairing amuse so
that becomes a little bit of a problem
as well
however the sequel model does address a
bunch of these issues so first of all
the nicest thing about the sequel model
is that it comes with a data catalog and
schema and so with that that allows us
to completely remove that from the logic
of our jobs the fact that sequel doesn't
allow closures is also great because
that means that you can't do stupid
things on the other hand it does limit
code reuse and it's so you know and you
can't invent new functionality that's
not built into the language so but UDF's
sort of bridge that gap but then you can
do stupid things in UDF's of course but
the EDS allow you to both do potentially
unsafe things but if you pay attention
to it you know you're in an unsafe
environment that's sort of good and then
also you're effectively extending the
platform for other people so this is
code sharing as well of course the
system guarantees reduce the need to
test a lot of things because those are
just built in the guarantees are built
in the system the semantics and all that
good stuff and also that extends to the
so the code surface to test debug and
optimize is reduced
some people find database tuning
complicated and query tuning complicated
but really it just means you have to
understand the domain and the system
itself and once you've mastered those
two things then it's actually pretty
easy to predict the runtime profile of
what you're declaring and change it if
needed
ok so let's talk about the life cycle of
a job in this paradigm so we're going to
talk about for compactness sake we're
gonna talk about the daily cliques a
life cycle earlier it was hourly so
we've got some analysts and that person
is writing you know sequel query this
very trivial sequel query and they've
parameterised it to look at the first of
November and get the output so one
assumes they're playing with this and
getting it just right and now they've
gotten it right and so now they want to
schedule it so they're gonna define the
domain of
a partitioning function they're going to
apply it they'll bind it to that query
and then they're going to go ahead and
push that into a central code repository
will have QA bot take a look at it do
some you know just make sure the thing
actually compiles and do some basic
checks it gets a plus one their peer
review comes and we get a plus two
somebody else is like has suggested the
vet query is actually well-defined and
then and useful so then it goes out to a
staging environment where we can do a
full cycle of that query so we get an
incremental incremental metrics what's
the additional cost of this query into
the system you know also it's in a
staging environment so your stakeholder
can go take a look at it afterwards to
double-check that that's what they want
and then the metrics are okay and so
then we're gonna push that into
production right and then now this is
producing data into our data catalog
that some other analysts can go and
start playing with so now they can
actually start thinking about doing the
same thing right and the cycle repeats
the point here is that the data
exploration language becomes the data
transformation language and with a
simple extension we can actually fluo
defy that entire development cycle in a
very very safe and very very scalable
way because thanks to Facebook hive
exists Presto exists and these systems
are data center scale compute engines
right so you can rely on them okay so
the declarative data processing dev
cycle just a quick recap of that so
write the query figure it out play with
it declare the domain of the partition
committed to the platform and then
because we're in this purely declarative
environment what's really easy to
institute a proper dev cycle for that
including code review and all that good
stuff so I'm gonna pass to data
processing at Crito so we're at the F of
crece oh and so what does this look like
accreta so here's our here's our stack
data flow at the top is this declarative
environment kuddle is our sort of
declarative slash imperative runtime for
the actual orchestration this is this is
the thing that exposes
depends on and and operators to build
DAGs we have hive you see presto here is
in a dashed box that's because it's a
new component how can we can talk about
that in just a couple of minutes
and then of course it's all built on top
of the hive metal store and your own
hdfs okay so that's a lie because
actually we also do non-sequel stuff as
i alluded to with earlier so we've tried
to do quite a lot to actually bring some
of these attributes of the sequel
paradigm so particularly a data catalog
to spark in scalding code and we've done
that via framework it's called hippo
that allows you to write in either spark
or Scala vein and but use the same tests
and all that good stuff and is bound to
our catalog system which is data disco
which uses the meta story so this is all
Scala land you build your imperative so
you declarative code but you bind it
imperative Li and you operate that
yourself oh right so I forgot so that's
and then we use how do you our source of
truth so basically everything has to run
through HDFS for us to increment we
build new data okay
so just some quick you know scheduler
porn image porn whatever so this is our
scheduler cuddle it's pretty standard
it's very much like air flow but just
gives you an idea so a bunch of jobs
defined and some are running some are
waiting based on resources that are
available or not you can take a look at
the log output of your job figure out
its status you can drink and Dylan drill
into the dag we have so this is our time
series scheduler so it shows you the
calendar so we can see that everything
is complete for this workflow except for
the 9th of November which is a green
square not of green cube or full filled
out square and so we can dig into that
and we can take a look at the status of
all the pipeline all the jobs for that
day and where they're where they are
also lineage so one of the nice things
is so we have post hoc lineage we
actually took the Google Goods paper and
because we do so much sequel everywhere
at every single step of the data
production lifecycle we're able to do
post hoc lineage in systems that are
outside actually of our of our system
because we actually sequel to Express
for example exports to go to take data
from HDFS and put into Vertica we use a
sequel of course to create tableau
workbooks that read data in Vertica and
we can parse all that stuff and we can
build this nice lineage so for this very
very critical report on the bottom that
our seats that our CEO looks at every
morning we're able to figure out what
the the path is for that for that data
reliably and then also we can have a
full understanding of the state of the
system because we understand partition
partition domains and so this is data
for example in Vertica so the catalog
extends outside of just HDFS so we can
understand the state of adjacent systems
so sequel for introduction why do we
like it well it's easy to schedule and
optimize it's highly productive no lie
we have about a thousand data set a
thousand jobs that are managed by two
ICS but I call that being productive and
that's really big scale right so I
didn't really mention it but you know
it's a hundred petabyte Hadoop cluster
it's a petabyte of data in Vertica so
this is you know reasonable scale so
it's non-trivial data engineering right
and we've got all that being safely
managed by well in one section of it
being managed by just two ICS it's also
easy to learn weave on-boarded
non-engineers on to our system so we
Confederate work which is great so we
become less of a bottleneck and it's
getting faster right cost based
optimization is coming presto is here
Microsoft Research is doing lots of
really interesting stuff about
materializing out portions of DAGs in
inside sequel queries and reusing them
so there's there's a huge roadmap for
usually optimising sequel runtimes at
the data center scale so that's
encouraging right ok why it's not
Universal at créteil or period so many
teams you still use spark and scalding
due to the ease of testing right you can
test those lambdas and that's all that
makes us all feel more confident about
our code it's important and also you
still you can't get past it sometimes
you need the Express Express
full-featured language like Python or
Scala many teams still also use spark
and scallion out of pure preference
right and perceived shortcomings of SQL
so when they should be using SQL they're
using sparking scalding we're working on
both of those points and our principle
work right now is finishing this
extension on the sequel stuff that I
just showed you as well as integrating
non-sequel transformations into that
whole data flow via UDF's and TV F's and
things like that so to be able to
include spark and tensorflow and all
that good stuff in the dag okay so now
I'm gonna hand this off to a Hawken he's
going to talk about our newest
infrastructure component which is presto
all right so yeah so given the
importance of sequel as a language and
declared internus and all that stuff we
obviously have to look at the you know
different sequel engines and there's a
whole bunch of them obviously there's
traditional ones like Oracle sequel
server no list of my sequel and so we
had the LIA been using hive so we have
hundreds of analysts world wild who are
you know doing ad hoc queries and hive
is like horrible because we're using
MapReduce and MapReduce is like overkill
in terms of doing you know you're
writing intermediate results out to disk
so we're looking as a project to you
know alternative to technologies and
obviously we're a little bit late in the
game to that we looked at the Impala
hive la Piedra Mew and spark sequel but
we choose presto and presto is not
perfect but it's getting better and
better as we you know almost every day
so we you know we tested out these
different technologies we get the orders
of
Mangan better response time than hive we
got orders of magnitude better resource
utilization there are some minimalistic
statements where hive is still makes
sense because we're essentially using
HDFS as a data lake so we have a huge
number of nodes so if you do something
extremely simple in hive where you were
just sort of create table a select star
from something pipe doesn't do a whole
lot of unnecessary you know writing up
to disk and then you have the the fact
that our Hadoop cluster is so huge
compared to our the number of compute
nodes we have for presto at this time so
it could be that there are there's stuff
that would actually be faster than hive
but it's kind of rare if you do try
anything non-trivial sequel query on
very likely Presta will if you give it
100 nodes or something like that
precedent would be way faster so we are
in the process of rolling it out we have
a initial cluster with a couple of
clusters actually with you know we're
gonna get you know we have a hundred
nodes that we have rolled out already
and we have another hundred couple
hundred nodes coming along so that so
that's pretty good we have about sixteen
physical cores per node and but 256 gigs
of main memory per node so that's
essentially our configuration and that
sort of tends to give us pretty good
performance we're not CPU bound really
we are more so we sort of have this data
Lake you know separation or computing
storage so our data Lake is on HDFS and
you know on the order of you know
hundred petabytes or whatnot so are we
roll out these compute nodes you know a
couple of hundred but compute nodes for
presto and the limiting factor probably
is to get it sucking the data out of the
HDFS you know Hadoop data Lake so our
primary objective for this is to for our
analysts to get given better
productivity by better ad hoc query
performance and also reducing our you
know cost because it's more you know
simile our hardware costs will go down
we're looking at the other use cases
other than the ad hoc queries for
analysts we're looking at using Presta
ETL transformations and our machine
learning we have a fairly large machine
learning community and they're looking
into using Presta for part of their
there's or pipelines for doing their
their work so creature has its own
private infrastructure we're doing stuff
in our own data centers we're not like
you know doing stuff on AWS or a servers
or something like that so we are we have
to do a lot of stuff ourselves that
possibly could be is like managed
services if we were using you know
public clouds but so so I'm going to
spend just a minute or two talking a
little bit about what it means to
implement some technology like presto in
your own data centers so first of all so
you have the file format issue so so
presto does not quite support all the
files
that's-that's are supported by high so
we are as a company we're moving towards
parque as a sort of standard as much as
possible and parque is generally
beneficial there's some use cases if you
have really wide tables with you know
you know many hundreds of columns where
it's maybe not optimal but you know for
the most part it's a good standard just
a lot of companies who are contributing
to that and so we're moving in that
direction
but that's a little bit of an has been a
little bit of an effort to migrate or
you know our data lake to that that
format testing is extremely important so
[Music]
we you know try to upgrade our Presta
version to the latest and greatest ever
so often we have our own pasta fork
where we have uh some you know bug fixes
and stuff like that we are trying from
TripAdvisor communities so we have some
you know creative specific no major
things yet but we are you know trying to
complete contribute back to the standard
presto version and we have done some
some stuff along those rows so we have
all kinds of tests running daily we have
a standard test suite we have canary
queries that run you know ever so often
to alert us to weather you know the
system is up and running and if it's not
not up and running we'll get an alert
and our slack channels and all that
stuff and then you have the upgrades of
course when every time you need you want
to upgrade you new version you need to
go through you know a whole bunch of
testing and and with unless the quite a
bit of of you know on time in building
out the testing infrastructure so we
don't screw up when we you know whatever
changes we can deal with that
other interesting things when you roll
out something like like presto is like
what's the cluster management you know
it's like okay we we have like hundreds
of notes how do you do with that do you
put them in one big cluster or do you
split them up in smaller clusters and
say hey you guys get this cluster for
this purpose and you know another
organization gets another cluster for
another purpose and so on so so and if
you put them all in big clusters and you
have the resource management which is
non-trivial it's it's you know it's not
press to specific you have the same
issue anytime you try to squeeze you
know a whole bunch of different
applications into a huge cluster you
know who gets resources and you know
what's the priorities and stuff like
that
another issue is how do we prevent rogue
queries because the you can have tools
that issue really stupid sequel queries
and you can have users who type in
sequel atom generate really stupid
where's that sort of can bring the
cluster sort of to its knees so how do
you prevent that I mean it's a general
problem it's not press too specific or
anything like that it's a general
problem with anything
okay so we have monitoring and alerting
so with slack channels we have on-call
procedures you need to do that you need
to have end-user trainings there's a
little bit of the take up if you want to
go from you know hive this sequel
dialect difference between hive and and
presto so that's pretty much it so give
them Justin oh yeah okay so I'll just do
last slide on that so how fast is it so
this is just Presto's performance so we
see that so first of all we see the
presto
I can return queries in just a couple
seconds even on you know reasonable
amounts of data six gigabytes of data it
scales well with volume so the second
query takes you know pretty much
linearly about the same amount of time
and scanning you
on the order of 55 to 60 million rows a
second but you know about two gigabytes
a second of data and we can also see
that it's actually you know many orders
of magnitude faster than been hive in
this particular query three seconds
versus I think eight minutes so that's
you know beneficial so that's the end of
my talk our talk thank you very much one
last thing is we're hiring so the
offices all over the world and so yep
anyway thanks have a question about the
performance how you you were able to
achieve that level of performance did
you do any partitioning for presto oh
the the three-second runtime yes oh well
yeah so that data's partitioned yeah the
I was select you know in that query it's
selected on a specific partition it's
also parquet so it does column training
as well okay and so that yeah all right
thanks any other queries in sequel we
write list better my office oh wow any
other question you got one over here use
that mic so more about the ETL process
yeah it sounded like you guys had some
hives some spark and what there was
another ones I've stalled in Scala yeah
it sounded like based on your
presentation that you guys might have
had spark in scalding you're moving away
from that into more hive et else is the
plan to transition everything over and
what has been the performance
scalability implications of that so it's
a great question we're just in the
process right now so we've basically
ourselves identified when we ourselves
have built stuff in scalding in in our
case that should have probably been
built in hive and so we're in the
process of actually migrating that right
now to hive and in the past we've done
in preparation for this you know
strategic shift we've done internal
benchmarks and we found that a lot of
times hive is actually faster than spark
or scalding yeah
and we attribute that to basically the
heuristic optimizers that are in the
hive versus naive really really naive
spark or scalding code but execution
engine are you guys using behind that
right now we're using just MapReduce
part of the roadmap is to explore tez or
a spark okay great thank you
[Music]